this is a data professional AKA data
analyst sleng engineer SL scientist
we'll refer to them as the data Pro
they've recently joined a new company
and part of their role requires them to
turn their team's manufacturing plant
dashboard from a reactive one into a
proactive one so that their team can be
aware of issues before they happen the
data Pro is here to help and du a is
here to help the data Pro the first step
is taking a look at the manufacturing
plant dashboard powered by looker all of
the plants real time structured and
unstructured data is loaded into Google
Cloud analyzed and presented here they
can see that one of the plants is having
some issues so they click into it to
explore immediately they're able to see
that throughput has been below Target
for a number of hours starting at 2:00
p.m. the data Pro decides to use duet Ai
and looker to learn why throughput is
down in the chat window they prompt duet
AI why did the throughput drop at 2:
p.m. duet AI responds with the
production line that the throughput
dropped for and since it knows the
context of the situation duet AI has
gone one step further and suggested
additional questions to ask like this
one which metrics correlate with the dip
from the response the data Pro can see
that there are some machine issues duet
has given some machine statistics that
our Pro will use to start diagnosing the
physical fix this is really helpful for
our data Pro without duet they probably
would have had to ask another data
engineer for help since this data is not
easily
accessible now our data Pro can see why
they've been tasked with making this
dashboard proactive instead of reactive
they need to build a preventative
maintenance model to identify future
downtime and avoid it in order to build
and ship a data model they'll get
started in big query Studio a simple
unified environment where they can build
anything they want including in Python
first they'll take a look at what data
already exists so they don't have to
start from scratch there are two data
sets one in Google cloud and another in
a different Cloud they see a throughput
table that looks promising as a starting
point they open it to see what the data
is and validate the quality of the data
once they open the table they use the
data profile tool to perform some light
exploratory data analysis they also see
that there are automated quality checks
in place which is a good sign so they
know this data is actively maintained oh
cool there is even an insights tab where
duet AI has already analyzed the data
and how it's being used and proactively
suggests insights for business questions
that our data Pro might want to answer
they decide to open and run one of the
queries and big query to further explore
the insights they appreciate how helpful
these insights are to build their
understanding of this data
quickly it looks like another data set
also has some reference data so they'll
pull that into the model 2 since they're
building multiple ml projects they
decide to do this in a notebook inside
of BQ so collaboration is easier duet AI
supports SQL generation and completion
so they ask it to help build a model
from the multicloud data that can
predict throughput based on the
attributes available in the notebook
itself they prompt duet by clicking Plus
Code and typing in the prompt to create
a logistics regression model duet AI
will even understand the request with
incorrect spelling and just like that
the sequel is ready that saved our data
Pro a lot of time it also interconnected
the data across clouds using a simple
SQL join in real time without the need
for complex operations or processes here
duet AI helps our data prob not just
code faster but also in any language in
any analysis tool to help them answer
business questions
amazing our data Pro wants to make sure
the model will actually run on realtime
data since it was trained on a table not
a data stream in the same notebook they
can start mixing languages in this case
using python first they use a few lines
to see the model actively running
against the production data and with
predictions the model is ready
prediction are a good start but the data
Pro wants to go further and actually
help the plant operators by giving them
recommendations for how they can keep
the plant working optimally luckily
there is some more data available this
time unstructured inspector reports that
they can use for this they use retrieval
augmented generation which is a fancy
way of saying that they will use their
own data and an llm to build an agent
with tools to connect to their data
these tools will help improve the
reliability of responses from the llm
and reduce hallucinations sounds like a
lot of work but they're going to do it
in a few lines of code first they'll
bring AI to the data in big query using
llms powered by vertex aai and
bigquery's new ml inference engine to
connect all these amazing models
summarize the reports and create vectors
or numeric representations of their text
to help with searches and groups ings
next they pass a question or prompt into
the llm to get the vectors and summary
then they use the summaries to ask the
llm for recommendations to get
predictive actions and the results are
displayed this would have taken our data
Pro a lot of time and effort to do using
traditional data science methods here
they did it in a few functions in a
couple minutes using the power of
generative Ai and all in big query where
their data remains
secure now the pipeline is deployed
let's see the pipeline results back in
the plant dashboard where the predictive
results are now displayed our data Pro
can even set actions using looker so
that the right people are notified to
take action on the new recommendations
our data pro has succeeded in helping
the dashboard move from reactive to
proactive using the data cloud and
generative AI to make it all happen in
minutes
securely and at scale and with all that
time saved they can now finally get
around to playing ukulele thanks to at
AI what will you
[Music]
build